and also what that does is
psychologically
these are secrets here I'm giving
everybody by the way
how is commercial work different from
other types of acting
it depends you know it depends on what
type of commercial it is
I mean you have commercials where you
have um
it'll be a serious
you know commercial dealing with uh
say drug use or whatever or maybe teen
pregnancy or whatever you know and they
might get a commercial to look more like
a TV or a film
okay then you have
commercial auditions where is really
Broad and high comedy like sitcom
I've done all different types of
commercials over the years where they
might have me do a sitcom type
commercial
you know or they might have me do
something like a more dramatic
commercial where you have to really act
or be able to pull that off
but the more versatile you are of course
the more money you make and the more
opportunities you get what usually
happens in a commercial audition Romy uh
well let me say this
since on a pandemic
um
things have pretty much changed as far
as the auditioning process
you do more self-tape type auditions now
people like me that have been doing it
for a long time prefer to be in the
actual agency with the casting people as
and possibly the clients
because see I have a theater background
so I still like to perform and be in
front of those folk but when you
self-tape you pretty much they give you
the specs of what they want and you
pretty much have to
try to interpret what they want from the
specs so you really don't know
necessarily what they want now if you're
fortunate to get a call back and it's
still you know self or like on Zoom or
something
then you know you know you you're
interacting with them so you get a
little more feedback or you actually get
a lot of feedback as far as what they
want
but I tend to uh I tend to book more
when I go into the agency more
because
um
it's just part of being like on stage
for me you know and a lot of actors a
lot of actors prefer to do self tapes
because they don't feel comfortable
being in the room I do because
I'm a ham
and you think that that maybe you would
book more because they pick up on all
the little improv nuances
and then when I come in the room
and I and and I tell people uh
when they when they go for a commercial
uh audition in person
I tell people I said how you come in the
room and whatnot those first couple of
10 20 30 seconds when you walk in a lot
of times they need to turn that
determines whether you might get the job
or whether you know they might like you
or not
what is it what do you think it is it's
just like eye contact or just seeing
your body language all of that
and I've been in situations where I've
walked in the room and the people hating
me
and you pick you know you could pick up
on stuff and I'm like okay
they don't like me I mean for whatever
reason
it could be any reason
I was in a situation before where um
uh a guy was saying that he booked a job
because
the uh the the woman from the Ad Agency
had a boyfriend that looked like him in
high school
you know
and then I've been in situations where
I've been in the room where I thought
they didn't like me where I'm just like
oh boy I'm not getting anything from
them you know as far as any feedback or
any warmth
and I leave there and you know on the
way home or whatever I'm driving and my
agent will say
they want to put you on a veil I'm like
Avail for what for where you just left
and then an hour or two later
they'll call my agent and say you booked
it I'm like okay and then when you get
on the shoot
those same people that were like
come up to you oh we're so glad to have
you here I'm like oh yeah okay then on
the other hand I've been in a room where
I've had to people just like gushing on
me oh keep going that's fantastic
nothing so it's hard to say it's it's
just so crazy about how the business is
and uh
and and you know you just got to just
play it by ear
you got to play it by ear but
commercials now commercials now are are
pretty much most of them are now real
people type commercials and they don't
do more they don't do as many serious
dramatic commercials unless the subject
calls for it but if you notice from TV
everything is usually kind of you know
funny and kind of you know and whatnot
because especially over the last couple
of years we've we've we've needed to
have people laugh you know and be
entertained and feel better you know
about themselves
and about the world yes
mainly just for themselves yeah mainly
the world
we all feel good about ourselves I feel
good about me
what are some do's and don'ts of
commercial auditions even even when
you're in the car checking your hair or
whatever checking your teeth what are
some things that you just know don't do
this and make sure to do this okay well
at an audition
when you uh
come in the room
don't don't
try to you know befriend people or to
especially on a callback situation you
know now when you go in for the first
audition usually in person you're in
there with a casting person or the
director casting director or assistant
and I know everybody so you know we'll
talk about hey did you see the game or
blah blah blah blah and whatever and
then they say okay you're ready we tape
it they don't leave out because I know
the people
coming to the Callback
unless I know the director and I know
quite a few of them I still don't
glad hand and hey how you doing buddy I
don't know I don't do that I said hey
hey how are you you know and the
directors usually when they know me say
hey good to see you man and what now I
say well thank you you know I'm a little
more humble like that and then I try not
to um
I try not to play to the crowd I try to
really get focused on the director
because the director is the person
that is going to give you whatever
Direction and feedback you need and I've
done it of course but sometimes you you
might want to play to the people in the
room because they might be laughing and
whatnot you know you know you got an
audience so that's not you shouldn't do
that you should just mainly stay with
the director and a lot of times actors
are afraid
to ask
questions
because most actors are afraid to either
come off like they don't know anything
or like uh oh I'm I'm imposing on them
no when you're in that room that's your
audition
and like when a director says something
to me if I don't understand what they're
saying I'll say excuse me uh I didn't
understand could you say it again you
want me to do such and such and this and
that and they'll say what they want and
also what that does is
it's psychologically
these are secrets here I'm giving
everybody by the way
psychologically what it does is it makes
you have a relationship
with that director because
you you you're going beyond what the
script of the commercial is he's giving
you Specific Instructions of body one
you said what he wants you're like oh
yeah okay
and then if you're able to execute it at
that point then that's a plus you know
in in your favor you know
so and another thing don't please don't
linger after your audition once you
finish your audition don't stay in there
and you know they say well hey you know
I'm glad you had me here and no no once
you're finished say thank you leave
because sometimes see you could talk
your way into a job and you can talk
your way out of it and I've done that
before I've done it
because you're human sometimes you do
that and when I've left I said why were
you talking so much in there I say that
to myself
then some of them I've gotten in some of
them I haven't but you got to know when
the you got to know when to leave you
got to know when to give yourself that
hook you can get out of there you know
you got to know and when you're on the
shoot as a matter of fact when you're on
the shoot
always and I'd say this to Young
inexperienced or just basically
inexperienced actors
always
say thank you to your clients when
you're done
no matter what they're doing
where they could be talking to the
director or talking to whoever
once you're done shooting and they say
okay that's a wrap and they say thank
you whatever
always go to your clients and say thank
you you could interrupt them no matter
what they're doing is protocol and they
will stop talking about whatever and oh
and you know shake hands say thank you
so much hey it was a pleasure I really
enjoyed this and thank you get it out of
there leave
of course you always have to say thank
you to your director and you have to say
thank you to your camera operator and
all of the crew but see I've been doing
this so long I know most of these people
like yesterday I did a I did the job for
some people the director and his company
I worked for a few months ago so
everybody knew me
you know and I know I've known those
guys a few of them for years so I'll say
hey good to see you how's it how's your
daughter how's your kids doing whatever
and like that and then one thing I do
like I didn't shoot my scene until the
end of the day yesterday
so when they broke for lunch they say
Okay actors and whatnot you know get
served first I hadn't shot anything so
the crew is supposed to wait I said oh
no when I got I stood there they said oh
go ahead I said no no you go ahead I
haven't done anything yet
and the crew is like wow I said no no I
insist you go ahead and I was one of the
last ones to eat because I hadn't done
anything I've been sitting around all
day
they like that the the the directors and
the crew people they like that because
you let them know that you are not
better than them you are part of them
see we're a team
see but now if I'm working the reason
they want us to go first is because we
have to get ready they have to you know
remake us up or change outfits or
whatever so you go first okay it's
understandable but in my situation I was
sitting around like this
oh no you go
and they they really appreciate that
they might not say it to you but it's
little things like that when you get on
a set
with that they remember
now what about when you're sitting in
the the waiting room let's suppose it is
an in-person audition and there's other
actors there are you talking to them are
you telling them about a commercial you
just booked what's protocol it depends
it depends on it depends on the um
the people you're talking to or I tend
to I tend to not talk too much you know
about it it's like we were talking about
Facebook earlier
I don't really talk much about what I do
on Facebook
about the jobs I book
I talk about other things like sports
they know about myself
and I talk a little political stuff you
know and people say you don't talk about
anything you do I said no I don't do
that for some reason but I've never been
the type of person that has done that
because it's like yeah you know
I come from I come from a sports
background where it's like um I was
always taught if you score a touchdown
you don't have to do the dance and
everything you have to act like you know
you already do that and it's something
that you already always do and you know
you're familiar doing so I tend to you
know like you know just kind of flip the
ball I didn't flip it much when I played
but I tend to just hand the ball off and
go back to the side I'm kind of like
that as far as the business when
something about me is posted on Facebook
as far as work I'm not the one that put
it on there I have friends that say you
know you need to put that on me I'm like
well I'm not going to do that mainly
because I don't know how and second of
all I just don't do that
so I tend to you know kind of you know
lay back on that you know well I mean
what if you give an audition and it's
not the audition you wanted to give
maybe the performance you wanted to give
maybe you didn't like the direction and
you felt it didn't showcase your talents
well that happens
nothing what
if you can't redo it then
I mean you got you know come on you got
days where
you're gonna be on and you have days
where you're gonna be off
and
if you have a track record as far as
being
a reliable competent actor
casting people know from from having
worked with you or know from your ex
from the experience of seeing your work
or knowing you they know when you're on
because
you had those days I mean like anything
on any job some days you don't feel like
going to work and you have to go and
then you
figure out a way not to do anything you
know like I used to do in Corporate
America which I got out of there quickly
but uh you you you have days where you
you on in days when you're off and then
there's points where you say okay unless
I can redo the audition then you know
you have to just deal with it but you
want to try to be um
you want to try to be grounded in
whatever you do
and that's basically from you know
knowing your your Technique and also
from practice and study
and I always always tell people that
it doesn't matter how long or how how
long you've been in the business or how
good you think you are you always have
to practice and you always need to
workshop and take classes and whatnot
because there's always something new and
you don't know everything you might
think you do
but sometimes you have off days and
sometimes you have to just accept that
okay I didn't do it that day
see where a lot of people have problems
in this business
is when they get themselves worked up
over the fact that they didn't do
exactly what they wanted and They
Carried into another audition or they
carry it into somewhere else and you
know they don't treat their dog right or
you know what what is significant other
because of that and that's really
ridiculous you know and when I first got
into business I
my my first teacher who was like my
mentor at that point
I went to an audition and I didn't do
what I wanted and I left out and I was
almost in tears and I was
and I called him up and I said it didn't
go well he says okay
why are you why are you upset like this
he says because it didn't he says
do you honestly think you're gonna do
every audition it's gonna be great then
he told me he says you know no matter
what you do
99 of them you're not going to get
anyway
and I said huh
he says most of the stuff you're not
going to get so why trip out and worry
about it just go in do the best you can
at that point and at that time and let
it go now of course it's nobody lets it
go but over the years what I've done is
I've been able to let it go a lot sooner
see so you can't worry about stuff like
that you just have to go ahead on and do
your best and just you know roll the
dice and Let It Go
do a lot of factors have negative views
about doing commercial work now no
back then
you couldn't get a star
to even think about doing a commercial
that was an insult
and even when stars D commercials they
will like go over to Japan and place it
or Europe where they got paid millions
of dollars like you know Paul Newman did
that he you know Paul Newman's fantastic
actor he did a lot of commercials in
Asian in Japan and Europe
and the star big stars will do that now
they get most they get most of the
commercials now
and they get paid major dollars
the rest of us they've started to cut
our money you know
you know it's it's kind of gone down for
the regular working actor you know as
far as the amounts of money
are these buyouts by the way
I'm not sure exactly how it is for the
Stars they might buy them out I'm not
really sure I'm pretty sure they do
because the money is so huge that it
would it would offset any kind of
session fee or a use fee or something
like for us you got a session fee and
then a use fee so I don't know I think
they might be a kind of a bio with the
Stars because but it's so far over scale
that they can do that you know
and is it different for internet versus
TV versus radio oh yeah well internet
now now you get like a flat rate for the
internet you know
whereas before you know they would pay
you
uh a certain amount every 13 weeks now
it's a little different you know
and then the uh
like a lot of people say oh you got paid
for every time it runs that's not the
case Too Much Anymore see that was
considered Network
but the problem with network now is
most people don't watch Network
television
most people are streaming
so now we're getting screwed on those
streaming contracts
like Netflix and Hulu and all those when
they show commercials
they give you a flat rate and that's it
if an actor doesn't have an agent can
they still find commercial auditions
they can because
um
a lot of the uh like like uh backstage
uh
and casting Network and some of those
sites you know
they they have auditions open call for
auditions but usually it's it's like
going through agents and casting
directors who deal with agents so it's
kind of tight on that but it's there
there are opportunities you know
what's your final advice to actors who
want to do commercial work any any
parting words
well uh I'll say that um
it beats having a regular job
because you then you know can focus on
other things you know if you're able to
get get jobs and you know work you know
I mean I haven't I haven't had a regular
job in many years imparting I would say
commercial work is is really
almost like the bread and butter now for
for most actors because the
atrical and TV work is is much less than
it was for
non-stars and whatnot because as we know
in the uh
theatrical business you know in films
and and whatnot
they tend to skew younger so a lot of
the older actors
that were like doing a lot of films and
whatnot they have moved back to TV and
also into commercials because see like I
said commercials no longer have that
stigma of being
low rent and beneath somebody because
it's so lucrative if you notice on TV
you see more stars doing commercials
athletes you know and whatnot they're
getting all all of the work and regular
folk are not getting this much work now
you know because everything is is moving
towards that I mean you got like um
uh uh Jennifer Aniston doing you know
cosmetic commercials I mean I just saw
JLo last night doing a a commercial at a
health club where she was talking about
something and it was for some product
you know and these are these are A-list
Mega stars and they're doing commercials
because it's easy work for them as far
as not as much time
the work is not easy as as easy as
people think but it's it's easier as far
as on your schedule and on and on on
your time
as opposed to like say Demi Moore might
get a million dollars for a t commercial
and she might make a million dollars say
doing a film but she's on set for like
what two weeks or three weeks you know
as opposed to doing you know a
commercial for eight hours and most
stars don't even stay that long
they leave they're like oh I have to go
and then oh okay you know because
everybody defers to them and a lot of
the uh advertising people want to become
our tours and become you know film
people so they tend to want to say hey
look can you check my script out in the
Stars say oh sure give it here they
don't do anything with it